jetzt ist es raus schließen von den 257
rappt auch nackt wenn er das tut jetzt
im talk mit den dreien deren album hrn
shn ich habe gelernt wie man es auch
aussprechen kann bald in den
plattenläden und online und jetzt im
talk die drei aus essen bis dann brand
heißt sie seien gut weil dir auch bei
dir auch das war draußen
ok coole deko muss ich mal sagen das ist
euer studio dass unser studio seit wann
sagt er
seit ungefähr seit zwei jahren würde ich
sagen wie lange vergessen 2005 40 gut an
oder
schöne zahl stark von den medien
boykottiert vom ersten jahren school
aber nicht nur die medien wir wurden von
allen wolken tier tapfer publikum ja ihr
bewundert von selfmade vor allen dingen
die schweine von denen wurden
boykottiert wir waren immer die blagen
ich bin sehr erwachsen ich werde dir
auch gleich auf platz und drauftreten
aber wie habt ihr dann fällt mir dazu
bekommen jetzt den ganzen tag mit euch
zu machen
schlicke droht ok nein die haben das
gemacht mit eurer vor muskelkraft ja
klar unsere arme sind stark nein wir
haben das kam einfach ich weiß nicht
mehr vergessen ja wir waren da auf
einmal und dann haben wir haben gesagt
wir sollen ins studio gehen und musik
machen dann ist gut geworden auf jeden
fall
wann ist der moment wo man sagt das ist
was also bei mir war das gestern und
gestern kamen nochmal zwei neue songs
die ich bisher nur halt im remix im
studio gehört habe direkt nach aufnahme
und die sind sehr geil
also jetzt habe ich dann endgültig
gedacht dass die songs wirklich glaube
ich doch alle gut werden weil wir zum
ersten mal nicht selber mischen und so
und aber es super und wir müssen auch
jetzt woanders aufnehmen nicht mehr hirn
im loch und dadurch hört man die songs
nur einmal beim rappen und weiß gar
nicht mehr was man gerappt hat wenn man
folge und dann sind die noch cool aber
man kennt sie nicht ist auch für mich so
also die sind jedes mal doch wieder neue
songs sowie ich habe meine partner
direkt nochmal aufnehmen entweder
vergessen und dann höre ich die neue und
dann
es hat auch was ganz anderes mal hat
nicht selber zu machen und einfach nur
kurz aufnehmen warten und dann kommen
ganz fette krasse neue songs die sich
mister reger ich habe noch nie mit
gemacht
okay sie mal sein ding gewesen aber es
ist schon so dass ihr das ein oder
andere wort schon mal feuer auf schreibt
jetzt ein bisschen so an wir gehen da
mal hin und dann guck mal was uns gerade
in dem moment einfällt wenn wir zufällig
vom mikrofon stehen
wir schreiben uns schon mal drauf aber
man merkt sich ja nicht alles
aufgeschrieben hat man hört ja auch dass
wir das ablesen wenn wir rappen für dich
schlecht und freilich schlecht ablesen
nein und das ding ist ja auch und wir
geben wir auch nen scheiß drauf ob wir
jetzt sinn haben
deshalb wir können da schon hingehen
überlegen uns 13 worte die sich
aufeinander einlassen 16 fertig es ist
schon so dass man nachher nicht mehr
weiß was meine zeit also ich habe ich
letztens gewundert dass ich sehr knappen
nach vorn zu hause
also ich finde das super dass wir diese
don't give a [ __ ] scheiße jetzt weiter
durchziehen dürfen und selfmade uns
nicht selbst mit uns da nicht bremst das
wichtig weil sonst können wir uns nicht
ausleben wie du siehst okay was bei euch
grund gewisser kreise
ja nein ich will jetzt auf jeden fall
nicht irgendwie so keep it real mäßig in
dieser schublade gesteckt werden und
dann das die leute sagen so eia seit
michael oder so weiß und dass die dann
sagen ja ihr müsstet schon auch so ein
bisschen diese zu dieser web
anforderungen um cool zu sein erfüllen
und deswegen haben wir dann ist das auch
ganz klar wichtig gewesen dass wir das
weiter durchziehen dürfen so zu sagen
was wir wollen ja unsere musik fühlt man
nicht wer die flöte
toll dass ich für meine musik auf jeden
fall manchmal so ich höre das undenkbar
das heißt ob ihr cool oder uncool ist
euch scheißegal oder also mir ist schon
wichtig um cool zu sein auf jeden fall
ganz klar was sagst du dazu schicken
also schon gesagt wir sagen wird nein
und uns das scheißegal prinzipiell
schubladen denken dass homo seid ihr
dadurch kreativer als andere oder was
ist euer prinzip wir machen wir einfach
ab gehen also unser prinzip ist auf
jeden fall dass wir einfach versuchen
krass zu rappen auf jeden fall und ohne
jetzt irgendwie uns da in gewissen
bahnen bewegen zu dürfen wir wollen
einfach krass rappen und dieses technik
ding macht spaß und diese rhetorischen
sachen machen spaß und dieses sachen auf
die schippe nehmen und durch den kakao
ziehen macht spaß ein bisschen lustig
sein die für musik machen macht keinen
spaß das scheiße diesen stimme klingt
aggressiver wenn er nackt ja finde ich
schon wenn ich mich ganz nackt ausziehen
dann kommt dieser weg aus meiner stimme
da sich jetzt schon das wirklich grüne
putzen wie ich mich ganz nackt ausziehen
ja aber wenn ich mich ganz nackt
ausziehen sorgen kommt drauf an wie hart
der song sein so rede ich will ja nicht
aggressiv klingen immer okay aber
manchmal und dann ziehe ich mich
natürlich auch nackt aus und das im
studio dann natürlich wird die scheibe
zugehängt nein
weggucken oder wie funktioniert nein ich
gehe extra noch zu
dann wollte ich das sagen ich brauche
schon ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit wenn
ich nackt bin auf jeden fall ja dann
kocht das in mir hoch
das heißt du bist exhibitionist ihr
werdet schon raushören auf jeden fall
war nicht nackt und wann ich angezogen
versucht herauszufinden sexualität
sag mal was an keule reden
ich war lange weg
ich wohne doch nicht hier ja aber nicht
jede man ja hier war ich nicht da
sondern stattdessen möchten
nein so lang war doch ein bisschen
länger eine kleine pause eingelegt
ich will cool sein endlich cool sein ich
wollte ein bisschen im mittelpunkt
stehen so ne ne das scheißegal ob im
fall bin ich jetzt nach langer zeit
wieder hier zum album oder mitgemacht
ich war vor dem album zeit lang nicht
dabei wollte die auf warnt davor die
uhren so dass nur platz geschrieben
scheißdreck mitgemacht alter wir haben
das album war ich eine mutter die letzte
gemacht ist so wirklich ich hatte
probleme seine konnte nicht hatte keine
zeit gesagt haben
hoffentlich ist durchgebrochen
ich hatte babypause
jetzt bin ich wieder voll im saft gut
abgehen und so hoch motiviert davon
handelt auch ein song
dass man aber dann eigentlich das weite
suchen soll wenn die frau gehört unser
album mit dem wie ihr lebt nicht so viel
zu tun sondern seien geschichten will
wollen nicht viel sein
nein web ist voll scheiße da könnte ich
ja nicht behaupten dass ich fliegen kann
oder ich voll stark bin so wenn man nur
dann erzählt wirklich so ist dann ist
das doch so langweilig er lebte nur
langweilige sagen langweilig nein
wir erleben nicht nur langweilige sachen
aber ich meine man kann sich noch viel
coolere sachen ausdenken oder ich meine
geht doch darum kreativ zu sein
zwei alben das erste mal mit einer
plattenfirma ist das bei euch ein
nächster schritt gewesen
ja auf jeden fall also hat sich ja dann
doch ein bisschen was geändert also an
herr ansgar heran heran
und wir
ja vielleicht nein ist anders geworden
aber besser das sagt man ja immer
geholfen mehr mehr rauszuholen aus dem
was er bisher gemacht hat ja keine
ahnung dass es einfach immer noch
dasselbe wir machen unsere chancen
liegen woanders wird sitzen immer noch
im keller
wir gehen nur noch mal neu aufnehmen das
einzige was sich geändert hat und
dadurch ändert sich nichts an unserem
sound und so was sie vielleicht sind
qualitativ besser abgemischt vielleicht
oder so das ist ja nur kommt allen
zugute uns und euch und aber sonst in
wir mussten in keinster weise irgendwie
jetzt rückschläge die arbeit abzunehmen
wenn wir jetzt diesen schritten
weitergehen würden auch ohne label noch
mal viele videos drehen blogs machen und
so weiter das haben wir vorher auch
gemacht dann wirst du deine fanbase
wächst stetig und das war so am limit
wie wir es alleine gehandelt haben
bisher dass das danach nicht mehr
funktionieren würde die sachen an den
man pünktlich zu bringen und einfach
dass das ist ein geben und nehmen ist
allerdings offen
spencer washing sein könnte da nicht
jetzt kreativer sein wenn ihr mehr zeit
habt um wenn sie abgenommen jetzt in der
klar sofern sollte wenn er nach vorne
arbeiten
du hast jetzt auch durch dieses label
durch dieses label dinge auch viel mehr
zu machen
ok also wir haben schon immer noch
dieselben aufgaben bis auf ein zwei
kleinigkeiten die uns abgenommen werden
dann mal 3 ich würde ja viel sagen ich
kann auch sagen aber im prinzip machen
wir immer noch dasselbe wir schreiben
unsere behinderten die halt nur waren
das auf und schwanz 20 künstler sagen
das ist ja sagen ja das ist mein bestes
album würdet ihr das sagen jetzt und
würde sagen es ist es geworden weiß halt
auch so viele sagen ja hokuspokus war
besser als 2 lässt sich darüber streiten
egal müssen wir jetzt ja nicht
ausdiskutieren das ist ich finde auf
beiden sind fette songs drauf und wecker
songs und jetzt sind es mag eine leica
store um so das ist halt ein versuch das
ist das beste album waffe gemacht haben
das ist krass
wasserstein
nach vorne was bedeutet für euch drei
abgehen dass damit auch zusammen hat es
euch weiter gebracht
also wirklich dass es ein übergroßes
live-album wir haben richtig spaß gehabt
das hatten wir früher
also es ist nicht leicht genommen aber
es ist für live sehr gut und wir hatten
einfach muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen auch
noch nie so eine einstimmigkeit was die
beats angeht und dadurch dadurch dadurch
hat jeder konnte so retten wir bock hat
also keiner war abgefragt und hat ihn
trotz sie irgendwas hin so es war dann
einfach immer nonstop bock gemacht wir
feiern jeden track von dem scheiß album
wir wussten nicht mal welche tracks wird
bonus machen sollen wir die alle so
scheiße sind also killer passamt auch
jetzt wieder treppen richtig heftig
krass als hat euch eure isaver beziehung
gefestigt
ich kenne keule seitdem der auf der
scheiß welt ist alter wo es muss nichts
gefestigt und löst oder sonstwas werden
schließen kenne ich fast genauso lange
wollte ich aber nicht wahrhaben
er war früher noch geistes kennt euch
aber ihr habt euch gemacht ich derjenige
unter dem das alles nie zustande
gekommen sind
würde die 2014 eine mit call wird 2014
album kriegen wenn der alles die hand
genommen alles klar davon aus dass
spätestens wenn einer in heftigen
drogentod qualvoll stirbt wie sich
unsere wege dann zwang aber ich glaube
wir trennen uns eher von
frauen gegenständen geschlechtsteilen
oder als von uns scheidungen sind immer
so teuer aber mit frauen hat abgefuckt
ab muss jetzt halt sein diese ganze ich
weiß ich will auch mal endlich diesen
leuten so den kann man ja auch mal zeit
geben alter das haben wir verdient weil
wir krass sind und wir halt nicht minder
erfolgreich mit unseren alten sachen
waren wo wir uns einen scheißdreck
danach die letzten zwei jahre gegeben
haben dann müssen wir das jetzt mal
durchziehen sage ich immer freundin
danach wird zwischen uns super
funktionieren wieder weil das so ist wie
bei dir momentan ich meine klar
begeistert davon wenn du auf einmal
jedes man jeden tag nur unterwegs bist
immer weg bis so aber müssen wir durch
die kommt auf jeden fall drauf klar
das heißt aber trotzdem zwischen euch
ist eigentlich die beziehungen fest das
ist halt was ganz anderes so wir sind ja
dass diese männerfreundschaft dieses wir
sind weiße normal alles redet nicht drum
rum trauen sich nur nicht als ich das
jetzt nicht zu sagen natürlich alter
pass auf ich antworte für euch ruhig ich
antworte für euch klar ist dass mehr
alter ey das wäre so heuchlerisch wenn
man sagen würde das ist nicht mehr
natürlich ist uns verbindet vielmehr
alter euch verbündeten postiert war dida
alter uns verbindet viel mehr spaß als
die ich brauche
gut dann können wir von euch noch eine
wahnsinnige menge erwartet heisst noch
zehn alben 20 31 ich hab mir gedacht ich
bin gespannt wie machen mehr als die
ärzte
ich schwör nächstes jahr nur nächstes
hier
ich habe es mir gebracht danke das waren
die 257 las und hier unten verlinkt
jetzt flair im vorprogramm talk zum
großen interview im november wenn sie
ein neues album erscheinen wird und in
diesem vortrag berichtet ihr über eine
beinahe begegnung mit lena da hat er ja
bei uns schon die eine oder andere welle
gemacht und commander krieger war bei
mir auch im talk er erzählt über die
gestiegene verantwortung die man hat
wenn man auf youtube so erfolgreich ist
wie er ja also den oder den könnte
direkt anklicken ansonsten ein bisschen
auf klicks zum löwen es sind inzwischen
mehr als es müssten über 150 promis
inzwischen je gewesen sein also viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann bei
banken